I set out to prove a black man to
receive a fair trial in the South that
we are all equal in the eyes of the law
that's not the truth of that movie
that's Matthew McConaughey a Mississippi
defense attorney in the 1996 legal drama
remember this a time to kill it's just
one of the hit Hollywood movies based on
the bestselling novels of author John
Grisham over his 30-year career he's
written 40 books which is so look at
that look at that wall John just sold
more than 300 million copies rich Emory
visits his Southern roots and confronts
racism again in his latest novel it's
called The Reckoning it's a story that
follows a war hero who returns home to a
small Mississippi town and then he kills
a popular minister without explanation
John Grisham joins us at the table to
discuss hello happy to be here always
fun I know so we set up the premise of
the book and you write in the book every
prosecutor dreams of a sensational
murder trial with a prominent white
defendant sure who kills a well-known
victim and you set that up nicely and
the whole book goes to the motive and
you keep us guessing to the very very
end about what the motive is that was a
challenge as the questions why did you
do it yes and so I wanted to keep you
hooked for four hundred pages not only
did you not only do you keep us hooked
the governor right before the execution
says look if you just tell us why you do
it why you did it your life will be
spared and he still doesn't tell right
right why sure it was based on a true
story yeah I think that you said that
you stole it's unusual to hear you say
you heard the story thirty years ago
yeah it was supposedly it happened in
Mississippi in 1930s in a small town
something like this happened and the
murderer would never tell why he did it
and he was hung on the courthouse lawn
and the governor went to Siemens the day
before and said look I have the power to
commute your sentence I will do so I
don't we shouldn't execute you okay
that's for that's for low-income people
but I'll save your life if you'll tell
us why you did it
and the guy supposedly said I have
nothing to say yeah
and they hung him the next day and the
governor had never seen an execution he
had a front row seat that's the legend
that's the story I hope someone can
verify that now that I've stolen the
story and published as a novel
we're waiting to see what's it write as
a writer to go I mean usually used to
whodunit so what's the difference mean
writing a whodunit versus a wide don't
so that's part of the mystery but that
was a lot it was a challenge there's a
lot of fun I'll tell you up front you
know the first chapter who did it yes
questions why and then and that's a
great question the motive was always
always there and you and you explore
since he was a veteran some of the
brutal things he went through in the
Philippines yeah I took the book took a
hard left turn about halfway through and
he went off to war and I knew that was
gonna happen I didn't realize I would
get that deep in the war but once I got
there in the Philippines the Bataan
Death March and all that it was
fascinating and I just the more I read
the more I wrote about his experiences
there and there's a reason for it later
later the book that we cannot divulge
now because we can't give the ending
Gayle's yes very difficult your wife
thought some of the scenes were a bit
too graphic I want to ask you though
about what you said earlier that you
first heard the story thirty years ago
you've written many books in that time
span why did this story still stick with
you all those decades later it's just a
great story now I didn't create the
story I heard it somewhere and I stole
it but I've had it for 30 years and it's
never gone away I thought when I heard
the story I wasn't thinking about
writing books before my first novel but
that some stories are like that I have
other stories that have been around for
a long time but I hope to get to one day
are they on a list somewhere is it just
in your head it's a list there's a file
there's a file called future novels and
I'll clip out something from today's
newspaper and put in the file and put in
the file and work on the outline I work
on the idea it's most of them don't work
most of them go away but the files
pretty thick yeah I like be honest point
that your wife Renee weighed in about
the war seemed that she thought it was
too graphic you really rely on her
advice she has given you advice about
how you write your sex scenes what sex
scenes I tried once sex change a legal
thriller yeah 30 years she's always said
men cannot write sex okay sexy good no
she says men cannot write good sex
things so I wrote a good sex scene about
10 years ago and a legal thriller uh-huh
and it was late in the book and she's
read a chapter by chapter as I'm trying
to get finished and so I gave her this
chapter with the sex scene and I heard
her laughing upstairs not good
not in a clown suit can't do it you get
you get two people who is time for him
to go to bed yeah what are you supposed
to describe body parts or something I
just can't do that let the women do it
okay I can't no okay what was that look
I can t remember what I've written
submitted there for you yeah I know John
and you're here for number 40
congratulations always such a good read
thank you congratulations
always fun to be here no f-bombs in the
book but I didn't use anyway I love them
I just said a well place one can be very
effective but I didn't say I love them
but you're right there aren't any in the
book that's correct yes my pleasure good
see my god great to see you again the
reckoning is on sale now